jenny just is one of just 23 self-made
women billionaires in the united states
and she's not very well known because
she doesn't have a consumer-facing brand
she got her start in the options world
on the the floor of the chicago options
exchange
there were so few women working there at
the time that there wasn't even a
women's bathroom
and she learned on the job how to trade
options and rose through the ranks at
her company it was a company called
o'connor she and another guy there
started uh their own firm doing doing
options trading and then she's just
expanded since then to a whole range of
uh different kinds of companies but the
most significant of her of her companies
is this back end kind of fintech for
fintechs apex clearing but basically
when you buy and if you're buying and
selling stock or moving money from one
account to another apex clearing does
this for a whole bunch of different kind
of more well-known uh fintech companies
the reason she came to forbes attention
was she cut this deal earlier this year
to merge her apex clearing which is a
private company with an existing
publicly traded what are called a blank
check company essentially it's a public
company with no assets that's in search
of a private company to buy the public
shell is going to buy her
private company
it's supposed to happen at a valuation
of 4.7 billion
the deal hasn't closed yet they're
waiting for the sec to sign things sign
off on things but even
if it doesn't go public at 4.7 billion
even if it goes at half the value of
that forbes still calculates that she'd
be a billionaire but we figured that
she's worth about 1.5 billion dollars
today based on her stake in the company
she's got some other investments as well
you know she's really a pioneer in
finance and options trading and she's
also trying to
pave the road for more women to follow
in her path she's created internships
inside her company so women can learn
how to trade and so women can learn
programming
and then kind of a fun thing is she
is a fan of women learning how to play
poker and she thinks it's a skill that's
good to learn because it teaches you how
to strategize how to take risks
what she told forbes is that she thinks
that women should be taking more of a
role in making financial decisions and
she feels like poker can help with that
she was a single mom when she you know
first started this company and then she
ended up marrying her business partner
um in like 2003
and she's really all about trying to
empower women to make financial
decisions
[Music]
you